tomorrow we're going to be doing a game
jam called lavendaire we'll have three
days to make a game using our own engine
hazel how are we going to prepare for
something like this
i don't know why don't we make a game
today to practice
all right final round of theme voting so
we went we're like fragile
that's what we decided yesterday that
was about it but we need to pick
something else today so how many are
there 16. let's press this generate
button five times
five times take the average no it'll be
all right one
two
three
four you can press it the last time
five
two numbers fresh
nice okay
so
yeah i guess so we did a fair square it
goes right so fragile so the idea that
we already talked about this yesterday
[Music]
and to make it really difficult we could
actually make it a sphere and then you
are literally like moving around the
camera's kind of following you
you're moving around like a spherical
surface yeah and basically you just have
a little tank or something maybe this or
okay
yes so
this is the earth and the the message is
the earth is fragile we have to protect
it okay like a nuclear war or whatever
okay that's actually like yeah that's
done
[Music]
why did we decide to do a game jam
before a game jam to be honest i don't
know and as i'm sitting here at like 1
35 a.m
the night before ludum dare and
regretting this deeply at least the game
we made i think is pretty cool
[Music]
dream that i had as a kid a nightmare
no that voice
it's also the very first game that we're
actually releasing made in hazel because
i spent the entire week working on the
distribution side of things so that we
could actually make a game during london
there and ship it for all of you to play
so yeah extremely hard work but this
game that you're watching here you can
go and download we've put it up for free
on itch.io there'll be a link in the
description below give it a try see if
it works see if it crashes see if it
even runs on your computer and hopefully
you'll have a little bit of fun playing
around with it definitely let us know
how you go in the comments below at this
point in time it's windows only and to
be honest i don't even know what it's
going to run on anyway as i've mentioned
lot of dare 3d game jam starting
tomorrow we'll be doing it as a studio
we'll be live streaming it all of us
will be live streaming actually
twitch.tv slash the channel is where
i'll be streaming it at this rate i
don't know if i'll be late or not anyway
i'm done with this i'm gonna leave you
guys with some gameplay goodbye
[Music]
pull
[Music]
run back
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
bye